astrolab développe la première station
spatiale laboratoire entièrement
robotisé pour faire de la recherche en
micro gravité notre startup développe
une constellation de satellites de
télécommunication très innovant afin de
permettre aux opérateurs
télécommunications aux opérateurs
mobilité du monde entier d'offrir à
leurs clients un accès à un Internet au
débit fait le temps de latence là où les
réseaux terrestres étaient
communications ne sont pas disponibles
CFA rôle c'est une plateforme de
messagerie pose quantique c'est à dire
que ça donc on fait du mail du chat de
la visioconférence mais aussi de
l'inscription de fichiers localement qui
est qui résiste à une attaque quantique
rencontrer des investisseurs rencontrer
les partenaires rencontrer de potentiels
talents profitez de revenus
du plateau de plateau de Paris Saclay de
se faire connaître mais aussi de
rencontrer les acteurs et l'écosystème
qui naviguent autour de la cybersécurité
et de la technologie deeptech en général
et d'être remis en relation avec les
acteurs des partenaires industriels des
partenaires académiques des
investisseurs qui vont nous aider à
contribuer au projet et à nous faire à
nous faire grandir
très bien on a pitché ce matin super
intéressant qu'on a pris des contacts
avec des
capitales des gens et des investisseurs
mais aussi des gens qui sont des
potentiels clients et le reste de
l'après-midi risque d'être dédié à plus
d'activités de networking avec tous les
acteurs présents aujourd'hui